[Applaudissements]
86 milliards de connexions et une
information qui circule à 120 mètres par
seconde
quelle technologie peut afficher ce
genre de performance votre cerveau et
grâce à lui aujourd'hui vous allez avoir
la chance de pouvoir entendre chanter un
atomes d'uranium
notre cerveau est une machine phénoménal
qui nous permet de pouvoir composer de
la musique de résoudre des équations
différentielles de se lancer dans une
thèse sur la philosophie de heidegger de
tomber amoureux deux ex d'expérimenter
des nouvelles recettes de cuisine tant
de bonnes ou de moins bonnes décisions
mais pour prendre ses décisions pour
être efficace pour aller vite
le cerveau a besoin de simplifier de
catégoriser de classe et de hiérarchiser
de mettre dans des cases en un mot de
construire des murs de temps en temps à
nos dépens mais c'est nécessaire avec le
flot d'informations qui lui sont fournis
en permanence par nos sens à ce sujet à
votre avis combien de sens avons-nous
habituellement à cette question la
majorité des gens répondent 5
en réalité les chercheurs en
neurosciences s'interroge à ce moment
pour savoir si on en as entre 9 12
ou plutôt 250 je vous en rajoute 4 au 5
usuellement connu
la vue l'ouie l'odorat le goût le
toucher
je vous en rajoute 4 tout de suite le
sens de la température le sens de
l'équilibré
la proprioception le sens qui permet de
se repérer dans l'espace la nociception
le sens de la douleur en fait tout ce
qui peut apporter des informations sur
notre environnement notre cerveau
pourraient être qualifiés de sens
pas étonnant donc pas étonnant donc
qu'avec ce flot constant et
ininterrompue le cerveau ait besoin de
simplifier en france on a une tendance
supplémentaires nationale à construire
des murs dans notre cerveau depuis qu'un
grand philosophe a écrit et diffusé ces
théories mais avec un petit effet
limitant à nos capacités de réflexion
si je vous dis je pense donc je suis
oui c'est des cartes un homme qui a
également écrit
la raison est la seule chose qui nous
rend hommes
grâce à lui nous savons que quand nous
avons un problème aussi compliqué soit
il il nous suffit de le décomposer
d'analysé chacune des parties de faire
une synthèse et de trouver la conclusion
tout problème a sa solution par le
raisonnement logique avec cette
injonction à faire passer la rationalité
avant toute chose nous nous retrouvons
nous français avec un fier esprit
cartésien
mais un bon gros murs qui nous isole
notre cerveau rationnel de notre cerveau
émotionnel
pourtant mes émotions sont une clé
essentielle à la prise de décision et il
est illusoire de vouloir s'en défaire
mais il est également nuisibles de
vouloir s'en défaire
qu'est ce qu'une émotion une émotion
c'est une information transmise par nos
sens pas les 5
les 250
sur un changement dans notre
environnement qui nous permet de nous
adapter à ces changements les six
émotions qui sont partagés par toute
l'humanité sont la joie la tristesse la
peur la colère le dégoût et la surprise
ces émotions naissent de la
transformation des stimuli de
l'extérieur par nos capteurs en
impulsions électriques qui circulent
dans notre système nerveux nerveux
jusqu'à notre cerveau pour avoir la
bonne réaction et depuis des millénaires
la réaction a été souvent une réaction
de survie des réactions et des émotions
comme la colère ou la peur sont
salutaires quand il s'agit de voir
arriver un danger et de mesurer sa
gravité savoir s'il vaut mieux le fuir
le combattre ou attendre qu'il passe
mais des cartes pas seulement lui mais
quand même nous à bien nos murs et dans
le côté réflexion et nous a demandé de
ne pas céder à nos émotions ce qui fait
qu'on se retrouve aujourd'hui dans nos
civilisations modernes avec une
injonction à rester équanime d'humeur
égale serein
zen et ne pas céder à nos émotions or
vous savez maintenant qu'une émotion et
en un courant électrique dans votre
corps vous ne pouvez pas ne pas les
ressentir à moins de se couper le bras
pour que ça ne circulent plus ou d'être
sous influence de substances médical
plus ou moins légales les récentes
recherches en sciences cognitives nous
dit ce qu' il vaut mieux connaître ses
émotions savoir ce qui les provoque
comment elle se manifeste chez nous et
chez les autres pour pouvoir adapter
notre comportement et avoir la bonne
réaction
en résumé une bonne décision se prend au
moins autant avec la partie rationnelle
qu'avec la partie émotionnelle donc en
quelques minutes nous venons de voir
deux tendances à construire des murs
dans notre cerveau une très naturel pour
simplifier pour aller vite pour être
efficace l'autre un peu plus culturelle
mais tout aussi répandu de ne pas
mélanger émotions et raison
ces deux tendances m'ont longtemps posé
problème personnellement parce que je ne
rentre pas bien dans les cases
par exemple j'ai un diplôme d'ingénieur
mais si j'ai réussi à rentrer dans une
école d'ingénieurs c'est principalement
par le français et les langues vivantes
plutôt le côté littéraire
un autre exemple j'ai effectivement
travaillé plus de dix ans dans les
télécommunications mais toujours avec
une activité artistique à côté de la
musique principalement du spectacle plus
généralement le spectacle
quoi de plus typiquement émotionnel que
le spectacle chaque jour dans le monde
entier des personnes qui ne se
connaissent pas se retrouvent côte à
côte dans des salles obscures pour rire
en même temps pleurer ensemble
tout ça grâce à une faculté magique de
notre cerveau les neurones miroirs les
neurones miroirs
ce sont ceux qui sont responsables de
l'empathie il s'active de façon
inconsciente est automatique dès que
nous entrons en interaction avec
quelqu'un ce quelqu'un pouvant être nos
parents notre pire ennemi notre meilleur
ami ou une personne sur scène ou sur un
écran
ce sont eux qui quand quelqu'un baille
devant vous vous donne envie de bâiller
ensuite ce sont ces neurones miroirs qui
font que vous n'avez pas besoin qu'une
personne ouvre la bouche pour savoir si
elle est plutôt triste ou plutôt joyeuse
ou plutôt en colère
et enfin ce sont eux qui sont sollicités
dans les salles obscures au théâtre au
cinéma pour vivre des émotions à
distance qui font que on a peur quand le
héros est dans un couloir sombre qu'on
pleure avec l'héroïne
quand elle s'est fait quitter qu'on
rigole tous ensemble quand le méchant
rate une marche dans l'escalier le fait
de vivre ses émotions par procuration
est connue des auteurs de ce spectacle
depuis des millénaires depuis
l'antiquité grecque qu'ils ont des
théorisé à cette époque-là en
n'utilisant pas même pour faire vivre au
public des émotions très fortes plus
forte que dans la vie normale et montrer
aux gens ce que ça fait quand on tue son
père épouse sa mère pour les grandes
tragédies grecques et leur éviter de le
faire dans la vie normale
normalement
moi en tant que musicien comédien
chanteur
je me suis intéressé principalement à la
comédie musicale et l'a immédiatement
vos cerveaux vont essayer de me mettre
dans une case en france quand on dit
comédie musicale en général on associe
saha de l'opérette d'offenbach un petit
con quand luis mariano
mexico mexico pas très sexy un peu plus
récemment en france comédie musicale
c'est le roi soleil et robin des bois
c'est roméo et juliette et mais c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus beau aimer c'est monté
si haut et toucher les ailes des oiseaux
et mais c'est ce qu'il ya de plus beau
oui on a compris mais en fait la comédie
musicale c'est un peu comme les légumes
il y en a pour tous les goûts y en a
pour les amateurs de variétés y en a
pour les amateurs de musique classique y
en a pour les amateurs de hip hop il y
en a pour les amateurs de jazz de rock
de funk de de punk pour les enfants pour
les adultes
il ya de tout enfin principalement aux
états unis à broadway une comédie
musicale c'est une pièce de théâtre ou à
un moment donné le dialogue se
transforme en chansons mais pas à
n'importe quel moment
au moment où l'émotion est trop forte
pour le personnage pour qu'ils puissent
continuer à parler et il se met à
chanter et dans la chanson quand
l'émotion est trop forte pour qu'il
continue à chanter alors il se met à
danser
c'est ce qui a été théorisée par les
auteurs et compositeurs de l'âge d'or de
broadway à l'époque mais ça c'est à
broadway
où les anglo saxons on cette conscience
que quand on est quand on se limite à un
seul domaine de compétence on évite
restreint alors qu'en france quand on
dit qu'on sait faire plusieurs choses en
général on pense bas dans ce cas là tu
sais rien faire bien c'est vrai pour le
domaine technique
c'est vrai pour les domaines artistiques
mais tous les acteurs et les actrices en
amérique sont formés dès les premières
années en théâtre en chant et en danse
c'est ce qui fait que des personnes
comme meryl streep ont des carrières
riche et elle est aussi à l'aise dans le
rôle d'out of africa que dans mamma mia
la comédie musicale hugh jackman qui est
connu pour le rôle de wolverine dans la
série de films x men a joué à broadway
le rôle d'un compositeur australien
homosexuel marié à lisa minelli mort du
sida en 1992 et qui est celui qui à qui
on doit la version originale de la
chanson je vais à rio de chanter par
claude françois
là je vous laisse imaginer wolverine qui
chante du claude françois il l'a fait il
a même gagné un tony award pour sa qui
est la distinction équivalente des
oscars pour le théâtre et la comédie
musicale aux états unis moi je vais pas
parce que les cases français ingénieurs
scientifiques à côté musiciens comédiens
chanteurs mais je ne m'autorisais pas à
être au tout tout ça jusqu à ce qu
effectivement je fasse des tentatives
que j'ai frites des murs que je les
abattent un par un au fur et à mesure et
de découvrir le bonheur de penser au
delà des cases et voir la multiplicité
la variété à laquelle on accède en
abattant ses murs en faisant de la
comédie musicale en reprenant mes études
en communication marketing pour faire de
la communication scientifique et épreuve
ensuite
en faisant une comédie musicale
scientifique
il y a quelques années une grande
entreprise française de production
d'électricité a voulu organiser une
soirée anniversaire qu'elle voulait a
particulièrement mémorable
après en avoir discuté avec eux ils ont
accepté le fait de faire un spectacle
une comédie musicale qui parlent de
leurs activités quotidiennes
ainsi est né le coeur des combustibles
la comédie musicale une ré demi
d'émotion liés à de la physique
nucléaire
le texte
la musique est la mise en scène a été
fait avec eux on les a impliqué dedans
pour qu'il puisse nous apprendre avec
quels outils avec l équipement dans quel
environnement y travailler au quotidien
et donc le texte et la mise en scène
sont truffés d'éléments de leur vie
professionnelle et joue avec de la
physique atomique des réactions
chimiques
le tableau périodique des éléments tout
ces éléments qui sont dans leur
quotidien professionnel
le personnage principal était un atomes
d'uranium
les autres personnages étaient john
charbon steve pétrole l'atome de
plutonium de zirconium de bord des
électrons je vous propose d'en voir un
extrait un petit extrait de 40 secondes
où la donne d'un d'uranium présente ses
enfants celui qui prendront serait dans
le futur en particulier plutonium que
vous allez entendre chanter et dans un
premier temps je vous demanderais d'être
attentif aux paroles que va chanter ce
personnage ce qu'il va que je vous
explique ensuite
taillé un état très tôt
j'y mets sur indien
[Musique]
maxi
c'est
on fait
maximum voilà
explication de texte l'atom de plutonium
qui vient de chanter commence en disant
je suis un métal très dense qui fait
référence au fait qu'il danse au fait
qu'il est dans une chanson à la la danse
des as est né se met également au fait
que dans le tableau périodique des
éléments
le plutonium est un métal danse d eux n
est ce pas elle dit ensuite chez les
iraniens je suis en transe qui fait
encore écho à la musique où elle se met
à danser mais qui scientifiquement est
vrai le plutonium fait partie de la
famille des transuraniens elle continue
comme ça je ne veux pas vous faire toute
l'explication ce sera un petit peu loupé
n'est pas tous familiers avec la
physique nucléaire je vous propose un
deuxième extrait où là je vous demande
d'être un peu plus attentif à la mise en
scène à la chorégraphie des différents
personnages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
on t'aime
voilà donc là si vous avez bien vu
l'atome d'uranium qui est au centre ici
bouger à toute vitesse et est
particulièrement rapide parce que
l'uranium est un élément qui va
rapidement dans les réacteurs nucléaires
et au moment où le personnage bleu qui
est la tome 2 hafnium la toucher il a
ralenti
il l'a stabilisé ce qui est conforme aux
comportements qu'ils ont dans les usines
de production électrique
tout ça ne se voit pas forcément mais
est reçu par les cerveaux en particulier
ceux des gens qui l'ont écrit et qui
nous ont donné ces pistes parce qu'on ne
le savaient pas forcément à la base et
qui font que ce spectacle a été pour eux
une soirée mémorable dont il parle
encore aujourd'hui j'entends encore les
chansons parce que c'était leur
quotidien l'émotion était direct et et
c'est beau tout ça pour vous dire que en
décloisonnant on arrive à un degré de
créativité bien plus impressionnant
qu'en pensant séparément ici on a mis
autour d'une table non seulement
l'auteur le compositeur le metteur en
scène la chorégraphe
mais le public également et tous
ensemble on a pu écrire un spectacle en
parlant ensemble en ne tenant pas compte
des murs qui existent censément entre
tout ça pour créer un spectacle vient
plus mémorables en conclusion si votre
cerveau à tendance naturellement à
construire des cases encore une fois il
ya des raisons pour ça
sachez que à chaque fois qu'il sort de
sa zone de confort qui sort hors de ce
qu'ils pensent hors de ces cases il va
créer des nouveaux chemins des nouvelles
connexions neuronales
il va construire des ponts pour devenir
plus efficace il va améliorer ses
capacités
alors à votre avis au niveau de votre
cerveau comme de votre personne au
niveau individuel comme au niveau
collectif est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
construire des murs ou construire des
ponts
[Applaudissements]